professor Walter storm welcome back to
Yale if I may I'll call you Nick
absolutely yes thanks yes because you're
my colleague well it's great to have you
back and thank you to have you back to
discuss with us this the issue of the
role of faith in liberal democracies now
you've written on that topic and your
account is not quite the standard one as
one finds it in many of the classical
texts books and great works of folks
like John Rawls can you say a bit of why
you d mover from those views classical
ones sure I suppose I should first
explain the sort of rationale of those
traditional news right yes so I suppose
the idea let me start a little bit
differently it's my personal a lot of
laypeople in Europe I know Holland the
Netherlands best a lot of lay people in
Europe are very hostile to the use of
religious arguments and public affairs I
think that's much less true in the u.s.
I mean in fact when you Hearst religious
arguments all the time and usually
they're not shouted down because they're
illicit or something like that so in
this country it has mainly been the
theorists political theorists political
philosophers and so forth who argued the
case and the case goes I take it
something like this John John Rawls is
the one who really inspired the debate
in 1993 with a book of his political
liberalism and Rawls's idea was this
that the one of the core principles of a
liberal democracy is that all the
citizens are to treat each other as free
and equal that's just sort of rock
bottom for him there are some other
principles but that's for Rawls I
suspect the deepest principle and his
thought then was that an implication of
that is that when we give each other
reason
one more preliminary matter almost all
legislation is coercive in some way or
another if there's no other coercion
involved there's a coercion of
supporting it with taxation very very
little legislation is just because it's
nice or something like that I mean some
monument in the public square or
something like that but most legislation
is courses so roses route thought was
that if if I'm going to support a piece
of coercive legislation then I should
offer you reasons and the reasons I have
for it should be reasons that you also
accept because if I support it for my
reasons and those are reasons that you
do not accept and you're opposed to it
and I go ahead and support it and even
vote for I am not treating you as free
and equal I'm viewing my position on
this as more important fundamental than
yours but we're supposed to treat each
other as free and equal so the rest of
the to other parts of the rauzein
position are that in our religiously
pluralistic society religious reasons
just in the nature of the case are not
one shared by our fellow citizens so
just by the very nature of the pluralism
so they're just disqualified on that
ground what's left them as reasons that
we couldn't expect each other all to
agree to Rawls's view was that just the
very idea of a liberal democracy
incorporates certain principles among
them this free and equal principle so
it's any called the those principles
incorporated in liberal democracy public
reason so you get the Rawls conclusion
that we should appeal to when we're
debating important matters of public
policy to public reason good friend of
mine robert goudie has basically the
same position but he thinks that what we
should he calls it what we should appeal
to secular morality but one way or the
other secular morality or these public
reasons that's what we should appeal
- because we can expect our fellow
citizens to share those we cannot expect
them to share our religious reasons so
as good philosopher you have made
plausible the arguments of your opponent
know why why why do you disagree for
several reasons one is one is there's a
I'll start with the philosophers reason
and then you get to the more practical
ones there's when you think about it
there's there's a deep paradox in this
position and the paradox is revealed
like this so you want to follow the
rauzein Audion principle offering
reasons to your fellow citizens that you
expect them to accept no for most of
one's fellow citizens we don't have any
idea whatsoever as to what reasons they
accept we just we don't know them we
know only a few people and among the
people that we do know we know that some
of them are ill informed um
boneheaded stubborn in their views and
so forth so everybody who holds this
position sees that you got to put
something kind of qualifiers on that you
get or or we would be stymied I mean
we'd never be in favor of any
legislation so they all go off into some
idealizing conditions like this offer
reasons that you can expect that all
your fellow citizens if they were fully
rational if they were fully informed if
they were flexible in their opinions
would accept now whatever you I mean
it's one question as to whether there is
any answer to that but now reflect on us
so if you think that they are reasons
that they would accept if they were
fully rational and so forth if you're
now go ahead and pass this legislation
you are in fact coercing these actual
people you wouldn't be course coercing
these idealized people right because but
you're coercing these actual people so
that's a paradox I think a more
important point Miroslav is this the
picture is then that an Audi stays there
is this
secular morality that we can all appeal
to in Rawls that there are principles
embedded in the idea of liberal
democracy now here's what I think is a
really interesting book by Robert Jones
on the he calls at liberalism's troubled
search for equality it's on the debate
which preceded the passage in Oregon in
favor just barely passed a physician
assisted suicide and what's really
interesting in this book is that he
quotes big lung is is that the debate
was in good measure written out I mean
it was highly articulate not just sound
bites and what turns up is that there
isn't any such thing as secular morality
there are secular moralities some of
these people were utilitarians in how
they thought about the issue some of
them were in effect an R and egotist and
how egoist and how they thought about
the position some were sort of romantic
expressive esteeming expression to your
true self and so forth so a bunch of
secular morality and a whole variety of
religious morality some natural law
theorists some turn more and sort of
Protestant divine command theory and
nobody's saying anything so flatfoot it
is God told me physician assisted
suicide was wrong so I'm against it so
there isn't any such thing as a shared
morality so that's against how these
positions right yeah and how about
public reason whatever your convictions
are when you enter into the public
domain
you should give reasons that are
acceptable or have potential of being
acceptable to everyone so it turns out
that there weren't that there aren't
enough sucks reasons maybe maybe on a
few issues but on this issue of
physician assisted suicide you're not
going to get from the idea of liberal
democracy to any particular position on
on that so I mean if I thought there was
such a thing as a thick enough public
morality or if I thought there was such
a thing as a shared second morality
I suppose what I'd say is use it
whenever possible but but there isn't
any such thing but your sense is also
not just that there isn't such a thing
right as something share your sense is
also that a religious person or to
somehow have a right yeah to express
their use rights of expression freedom
of expression and also to advocate and
be religious person in his or her own
way yeah so that's my third basic
position there are a lot of religious
people there are quite a few religious
people who are willing to I go down
Howdy's line I suppose of thinking in
terms of second morality and then their
religion is some kind of addition to
that but a lot of religious people as we
both know as anybody knows think about
these basic political issues in
religious terms and some of them a lot
of them probably find themselves unable
to think about these issues in any other
terms that was just are the terms oh
they they hear somebody else talking
about them in national interest terms
maybe or purely econometric term but
that just feels before me wrong to them
so in a liberal democracy one of the
basic planks is that everybody has the
right to exercise their religion as they
see fit and so it it seems to me that to
silence such people to silence those
reasons is a violation of one of the
fundamental of the opening commitment of
the u.s. bill of rights to freedom of
religious exercise yeah do you think
also that there is a there is a kind of
social value to allowing people to
express their public views to air them
in the very act of expressing them in
the public setting they'll reflect also
on them and how they're received by
others it will give opportunity larger
public to examine those arguments to
practice something like 'man and
criticism to kind of deconstruct them
from within and either strengthen them
or weakened and debate then starts going
on yeah so I think two things happen
then
we allow people to provide it they do it
in the right way when when we allow them
to offer whatever arguments seem to them
relevant and cogent and so forth one is
that what I've experienced is this that
when I listen listen for example to a
Jewish person's take on some political
issue often I feel that I've learned
I've learned something of great
importance that would not have occurred
to me all by myself and was certainly
not of a would not even have been voiced
if I'd said to this person hey look you
got to use neutral arguments I don't
want to hear any of your Jewish and
something mysterious takes place there
which which I can only describe as you
make allowance for Martin Luther King
speeches were typically very Christian
but lots of people were inspired by them
without converting to Christianity and
they made allowance they they learned
something of great importance they said
well I would have said it differently
but I hadn't thought of it so if we if
we muffle all the distinct takes on
important moral and political issues I
think we we've we've seriously
impoverished myself that that's my
experience I've learned from reading
Jewish commentators especially on others
as well but especially Jewish and the
other point that you hint at allowing
these other voices into the public
debate may be forces of too strong well
forces them also to to not just shout
but to think through their position with
greater care to work it out to
articulate that's what was interesting
once again about the Oregon debate there
was a process and the first statements
of the arguments were pretty primitive
but everybody forced everybody to state
their position more
particularly and so there was a great
gain in public public insight as to what
the real issues were that's very
disparaging so if I heard you rightly
you in in disagreeing with the position
like Rawls as you said well there isn't
such a thing really yeah as the public
reason to you said well even if they
were religious folks whose lives are
shaped by their religious convictions or
to have right to express their views and
third is the public in general in each
position in particular maybe third is
the sort of public good are you better
right right sorry be reversed and so
there's a public good kind of an
argument do you think that so I'm
persuaded you're not surprised right
that applies to democracies only at a
certain level of development at certain
level of identification with the
democratic process itself what
conditions in terms of how democracies
are understood how there are embrace
need to be satisfied if any for position
like yours to make sense obviously the
response to your position might be well
if you let all these religious people
speak their mind we're gonna have
cacophony and worse than cacophony we're
gonna have a clashes we're gonna throw
back into kind of religious wars kind of
the specter of religious wars is that
involved yeah I take you to disagree
with that but but can you talk about a
bit about conditions that need to be
satisfied for this to be a fruitful
process right so I think democracy
democracy is is a much richer concept
than just voting I fear u.s. foreign
policy often thinks if you can get them
to vote and then they've been
democratized so I'll put it like this a
curious a curious feature of the Rawls
Audi position is that they talk very
little about votes
and when you think about it you can sort
of see whether it is that the goal is
consensus because only consensus would
legitimate the liberal democracy absence
of consensus meaning means somebody is
coerced and that for them means that
somebody is not being treated as free
and equal I on the contrary think that a
fair vote is of the essence of democracy
can we never get consensus and then and
this speaks to your question and then
what's essential to the existence and
the endurance of democracy is that the
losers are willing to live with losing
the vote they don't try to they're not
deeply angry they don't try to upset the
process because they lost and so forth
but they're willing to live with the
vote presumably on the assumption that
they aren't going to lose every vote so
tolerance and in that very specific
sense tolerating the presence of the
other and saying okay we lost the vote
we're still going to work together and
we're jointly going to defend and
preserve this liberal democracy I think
is that is that the very heart of it now
it has to be preceded that that vote in
my view by lots of dialogue which is
fair and not abusive insofar as we can
make it non abusive and so forth but but
when I see when I watch you rock from a
distance it looks to me as if it's
constantly teetering on the edge of the
losers not willing to live with losing
the vote constant threats being made
well if that happens we won't we won't
share in the oil or we're gonna pull out
we Kurds are going to pull out or
something like that now that's that's
the deepest menace to a democracy so did
I hear right lis that there has to be a
general public a kind of sense that we
have a stake in this democratic process
as democratic process whether we are
winning or losing any given a battle
so certain identification with
democratic ideals and democratic
practices so so so if you have a deeply
divided polity on religious matters
would you still be able to have the kind
of robust public voice that you are
advocating admittedly for a very
different situation namely for our
liberal democracy in the United States
or in the Western countries yeah broadly
probably not probably not I mean it part
of part of the history I taken of how
liberal democracy emerged in the West
well there's a document apparently by
Philip De Mornay in which he was
apparently was a Protestant but the
document is anonymous and you represents
himself as Catholic in the document and
what he says is it would take - it will
take too much blood to continue the
current policy we so this is not a
rousing defense of liberal democracy
it's saying the alternative is we're
Emily slaughtering each other so that's
how we must face it it didn't just
emerge out of everybody he's embracing
of lofty ideals it Western Europeans
began to say what else
AHA so in a sense what you what you're
saying is not that liberal democracy
isn't that liberal democracy of the kind
that you describe isn't for those kinds
of situations but they may have
practical reasons namely stopping the
spillage of blood right in order to
embrace it comes a certain point when
they say this yes this can't go on and
and one might argue that if religious
voices are not allowed to be heard
the tendency might be to turn into
aggressive politically aggressive
fundamentalists right war undermining
the democratic process is such we're
filled with resentment and a kind of
rightful resent yeah yeah for being
silenced and and Grantham is a deep sort
of menace to the to the polity
- what - what agree do you thing that
the notion of liberal democracy and the
particular versions the version that you
are advocating is a plant that not just
has de facto grown on a broadly
culturally understood Christian soil but
that it needs some such soil in order to
thrive is it transportable to other
religious climates I think we don't know
the answer to that question I don't
think I know yeah I don't think any of
us knows the answer to that question is
there something peculiar to Christians
judeo-christian tradition that's
certainly word originated but I don't
know the answer to that question it's
really I think it's probably the most
important question facing us in the
world today yeah I mean it's not clear
to me yeah that democracy cannot
flourish and basically Islamic countries
but in a sense what you're saying right
you're not saying here's a kind of
general theory of democracy dropped as
if with the sky cook from above you're
saying I as a Christian philosopher
having grown in a particular situation
this is how I see it and in a sense
you're offering that to the wider world
community would that be yes yes so two
things that I emphasized the fact that
it did in fact emerge in a crisis
situation where Europe was full of
slaughter but I do think that there's
some other crucial piece of it
u.s. liberal democracy i supposes is
most art philosophically articulated in
the u.s. by virtue of how it began and
the phone they highly articulate Philip
founders and so forth you liberal
democracy here is a right space
democracy very clearly and
lots of good historians now have shown
that the idea of natural rights becomes
articulated in among the 12th century
Canon lawyers in the West a canon lawyer
is somebody who's concerned with
developing church law but church law in
the 12th century Western Europe church
law covered most laws so it was canon
law yes but it was law and that's
fascinating so in the 12th century these
Canon lawyers basically lawyers begin
talking about the rights of aliens that
is the rights of people who are not
members of your community the rights of
foreigners the rights of the poor
I mean rights are all over the place so
I think the basic question is this
suppose you have a culture which simply
does not think in terms of Rights does
not think in terms of violating somebody
that that's that's a way of thinking
that does not occur to them not part and
it's possible and there are moral
cultures in which rights just play no
role would it be possible for liberal
democracy to emerge in a culture where
the idea of rights is just plain absent
uh when I first went to South Africa in
76 what bowled me over is that the
Afrikaners refused to discuss the issue
there in terms of justice but said
charity and benevolence were the issue
they recited individual acts of charity
and they said that the whole system of
apartheid was a was a act of great
social charity there are these 11 or so
different nationalities in South Africa
and the Afrikaners thought that what
would be wonderful is that each of them
would find his own identity and you
can't find your own identity if you're
all mixed together so that they had to
be separated and hence it was an act of
great charity on their part benevolence
to institute apartheid no talk about
rights how can you how can you have a
liberal democracy and if you're thinking
along those lines you
have a vote right but liberal
democracies is just so I'm thinking
nurse laughs let a culture in which the
idea of every human being carrying
certain rice that must not be violated
if that's missing I'm not sure that a
stable liberal democracy you can have
votes but what do you have a liberal
democratic culture but invert that if
the Cultural Rights is present
significant preconditions for liberal
democracy are given yes that would that
yes is that also what you would say
right and there are Islamic scholars who
contend that whatever be the case with
lots of strands of Islam Islam in fact
has all the potentials for an art highly
articulate account of Rights and as it
turns out a language of Rights I'll be
differently understood is almost the
universal moral code this day so in that
sense it's it looks like at least
potential yes there from thinking what
might what might need to happen to a
religion to a religious faith so that it
would have a stake in liberal democracy
how do you how do you think about
exclusivist religious claims in
conjunction to what it seems to me like
if your firm liberal democracy you've
got to affirm something like a pluralism
as a political project yeah how do you
how do you think of these on the one
hand exclusivist religious claims on the
other hand the need of these religions
also to affirm pluralism as a project
political project so it seems to me a
religious group can unmalted them do say
that we are view humanity's relation to
God is the correct one the other people
have it in some way wrong I mean if you
don't say that then I guess you join the
other ones right it's it's definitely
possible to say that and at the same
time to say
it's profoundly wrong for me to put
those others under some sort of coercion
or to give them second-class citizenship
if I think that they as well as I bear
God's image and am loved by God then no
matter what religion they happen to hold
I I as a religious person say to myself
there are lots of things I must never do
to them or I am violating them and God
and I I think it's that religions have
concentrated on their exclusiveness as
you call it and have failed to to fully
be awake to the character of this other
human being whether or not they're
outside of the religious school so so a
certain sense of religious
transformation in the sense that needs
to happen that um he's authentically
religious right right so what I hear you
saying is not religion needs to adjust
itself to democratic demands what I hear
you saying is there are religious
convictions that are so deeply profound
at least when commissioned a tradition
that cannot but make you into something
somebody interested in political plural
that's my view so instead of
concentrating always on the
exclusiveness and we got it right and
they got it wrong and so forth for for
everybody at least in the Abrahamic
religion to keep in mind that human
beings won on all our creatures beloved
by God and created in the image of God
and that that just means there are lots
of things I may never do to them so
that's not right so that's not getting
into some alien view that's taking with
total seriousness your own religious
views so I think when
the aimer Abrahamic religions at least
recognize their give full sway to their
deepest convictions they are led to be
supporters of liberal democracy in most
situations you know I have to happen to
believe that in the world today
interaction and relationship between
democratic traditions and faith
traditions are one of the great
challenges of today in the context of
globalization processes and during this
conversations you have given us reason
to hope that both democratic traditions
can be faith friendly and that faiths
can be democracy friendly thank you very
much for this thank you sir thank you